do you have hope that humans
will colonize
the uh the galaxy so expand out become a
multi-planetary species another way of
asking that from a gravitational and a
propulsion perspective do you think
we'll come up with ways to travel close
to the speed of light or maybe faster
than the speed of light
which would make it a whole heck of a
lot easier to to expand out into the
into the universe
yeah uh
well i think um
you know we're not
that's
very futuristic i think we're not that
far from being able to
make a one-way trip to mars
that's a that's then a
question of uh
whether people are willing to send
somebody on a one-way trip but oh i
think they are i think there's a lot of
ex the explorers burn bright and within
their hearts yeah exactly people wanting
to die so
the opportunity to to explore new
territory yeah so uh
you know with this this recent
landing on mars is pretty impressive
they have a little helicopter that can
fly around you can imagine
you can imagine in the not too distant
future that you could have i don't think
civilizations colonizing i can envision
but i i can envision something more like
the south pole
we haven't colonized
antarctica because it's
all ice and cold and so forth but we
have
uh
stations so we have a station that's
self-sustaining at the south pole that
i've been there
it has oh really yeah
what's that like
uh and
because that there's parallels there to
go to mars it's fantastic it is what's
the journey like
the journey involves going
the south pole station is run
in the u.s by
by the national science foundation
i went because i was on the national
science board that runs the national
science foundation
and so you get a vip trip if you're
healthy enough to the south pole to
see it
which i took
you fly from the u.s to australia to to
uh
christ church in australia southern
australia
and uh
from there you fly to mcmurdo station
which is on the coast and it's the
station with about a thousand people
right on the coast of antarctica
uh it's about a
seven or eight hour flight and they
can't predict the weather so
when when i flew from
church to mcmurdo station they tell you
in advance you do it in a military
aircraft they tell you in advance that
they can't predict whether they can land
because they have to land on
reassuring
yeah and so about
halfway the pilot got on and said uh
sorry this is a they call it a boomerang
flight you know boomerang goes out and
goes back
so we had to stay a little while in
christ church but then we eventually
went to
mcmurdo station and then
flew to the south pole the south pole
itself
is uh
when i was there it was minus 51 degrees
that was summer
uh
it uh
zero humidity
and uh
and it's about
11 000 feet altitude
because it's
never warm enough for anything to melt
so it doesn't snow very much but it's
about 11 000 feet
of snowpack so you land in a place
that's high altitude
cold as could be
and dry and incredibly dry
which means you have a physical
adjustment
the
place itself is
it's fantastic they have this great
station there they they do astronomy at
the south pole nature wise is it
beautiful
what's the is what's the experience like
or is it like visiting any town
no it's very small there's only um
less than 100 people there even when i
was there
you know
there were about
50 or 60 there and in the winter there's
less half of that their winter when yeah
it's real cold it gets really cold yeah
and but it's but it's
it's a station i i think
and that's
i mean we haven't gone beyond that uh
on the coast of antarctica they have
greenhouses and they're self-sustaining
in mcmurdo station but we haven't really
settled more than
that kind of thing in antarctica which
is a big
a country or you know
uh
big plot a big
piece of land so
i don't
i can't envision kind of
colonizing at people living so much as
much as i can see
uh
the equivalent of the south pole station
well in in the computing world there's a
idea of
you know backing up your data and then
you want to do off-site backup
uh you know to make sure that if the
whole thing burn if your whole house
burns down then you could have a backup
offsite of the data i think the
difference between antarctica and uh
and mars is mars is a off-site backup
that if we have nuclear war whatever the
heck might happen here on earth it'd be
nice to have a backup elsewhere and uh
be nice to have a large enough colony
where we sent a variety of people except
like
uh
a few silly astronauts in suits you know
have an actual vibrant
um get a few get a few musicians and
artists up there get a few uh
maybe like one or two computer
scientists those are essential maybe
even a physicist so i'm not sure yeah
maybe not so that comes back to
something you
talked about earlier which is fermi the
paradox family's paradox because you
talked about having to escape yeah
but
and so the missing one one number you
don't know how to use in fermi's
calculation or drake who's done it
better is how long do civilizations last
yeah
before they
are we you know we've barely gotten to
where we can communicate with
electricity and magnetism and maybe
we'll wipe ourselves out pretty soon so
are you hopeful in general like you
think we've got another couple hundred
years at least
or are you worried
well
no i'm i'm i'm hopeful but i don't know
if i'm hopeful in the long term
you know if you say
you know
uh
are we able to
to go for another couple thousand years
i'm not sure i you know think
we have where we where we started the
fact that we can do things that don't
allow us to
kind of keep going or there can be
whether it you know ends up being a
virus that we create or
ends up being the equivalent of nuclear
war or something else
it's not clear that we can control
things well enough
you